[Musique]
you're gonna be scared
vous êtes décidément accro à tous ces
vidéos d'histoires d'horreur de trucs
pas anormaux et sert à vous aimer ne pas
dormir c'est bizarre vous aimez vous
faire du mal vous aimez vraiment
souffrir qu'une ce bizarre écoutez après
m'être fait recelés par énormément de
gens en premier vous que j'ai décidé de
refaire une vidéo horreur c'est même pas
je me se faire seul essai c'était une
prise d'otages on m'avait pris en otage
vraiment vous même menacé et en ce cas
il n'y a pas tout le temps des trucs
flippant cool a raconté ok alors je
prends mon temps les deux ou trois
dernières vidéos de ce genre on était
sur le sobre et dit let's not me tous
des gens témoigne de trucs un peu
flippant voire triplé manqué version
arrivée de vraies histoires aujourd'hui
on retourne sur un format un peu plus
vieux le format thread twitter on avait
d'ailleurs commencé ce format avec des
threads tweets et oui je vous le
rappelle est bien écouter aujourd'hui on
revient aux sources avec un nouveau ce
raid qui est français et qui est je
trouve excellent bref c'est parti pour
le strait de helg à tayrac on va appeler
michael tout au long de l'histoire pour
des raisons de clarté et à la fin on ira
tous sur des forums obscures pour en
savoir plus sur tout ça parce que ça va
nous faire bien bad et michael explique
qu'il a remonté récemment de sa cave
une malle pour s'en servir comme élément
de déco ou comme support comme il dit
tout va bien me direz vous et je suis
déjà pas d'accord avec lui ne monte pas
une malle quai dans votre cave depuis un
siècle pour faire la déco de votre
chambre
c'est pas un bon plan vraiment il
explique que récemment elle s'est mise à
faire du bruit
la [ __ ] de mal qui n'est pas une bonne
décoration plus vraiment idiot est
formel il ya du bruit qui vient de
l'intérieur de la malle aussi chelou que
cela puisse paraître ce serait trop
simple qui puisse le vrai tout de suite
mais qu elle précise qu'elle est
verrouillée par un cadenas don à sa
connaissance personne n'a la clé nickel
du bruit qui vient d'une malle qui était
dans sa cave depuis un siècle
et personne n'a de claix génial il va
ensuite décrire un peu la malle en
expliquant qu'elle fait environ un mètre
vingt de l'eau qu'elle est très ancien
et quelle date probablement d'avant
guerre on est donc sur un vieil objet
vraiment quelques minutes plus tard mais
qu'elle est surpris par un nouveau bruit
qui vient de l'intérieur de la malle
il décrit un peu le bruit et c'est
apparemment une sorte de mélange entre
un coup un craquement et un bruit
d'ongles qui gratte
aucun de ces trois bruyne est rassurant
aucun bref la nuit passe michael réussi
à dormir en pré saison qu'il a réussi à
s'endormir à partir du moment où les
bruits on
op voilà l'intro et maintenant on va
suivre l'histoire sur plusieurs jours
parce que michael a fait des tweets
quasiment tous les jours à propos de
cette histoire là qui a vite dégénéré le
lendemain mais qu'elle dit avoir passé
une très bonne nuit et revient sur ce
qu'il a dit la veille en expliquant que
c'est pas un cadenas qui ferme la malle
mais que c'est une serrure directement
incorporées dans la malle et mais l on
s'en bat les couilles tu te sois trompé
l'erreur est humaine parle nous de la
malle c'est quoi cette malle bordel on a
droit à une photo et la malle ressemble
à ça rien d'étonnant c'est vraiment une
malle classique qui a deux petits trous
de serrure une grève est rouillée
l'autre qui semble avoir été forcée
d'après les dires de michael et il
soulève un point intéressant pourquoi il
ya qu une serrure qui a été forcée et
pas l'autre pourquoi la personne s'est
arrêté en si bon chemin les gens vont
répondre à michael en lui disant écoute
enregistre le bruit que tu entends qui
vient de la malle pour qu'on puisse
essayer de trouver ensemble pour qu'on
puisse aider à trouver une explication
rationnelle par rapport à ce bruit à
trouver ce que ces hectares de chez dtz
une autre amie a donc une bonne idée
c'est de mettre son téléphone en mode
dictaphone et de le poser à côté de la
malle toute la nuit pour le lendemain
des roches un truc que je sais pas
combien d'heures essayer d'y trouver le
fameux bruit qu'il a entendu à multiples
reprises et qui vient de l'intérieur de
la malle mais qu'elle se réveille
tranquillement à 11h30 le bas tarifs
fait attendre il explique qu'il avait
une soirée la veille etc
mais ça a marché il a trois heures
d'enregistrement je sais vous êtes déçu
moi aussi l'enregistrement s'est arrêté
au bout de trois heures mais il a quand
même réussi à chopper 2 3 moment où il
ya eu des craquements et des coups qu'on
peut entendre en mettant le son très
fort et coup tout ça
bah c'est le craquement moi qui me
dérange là ça se trouve dans la malle il
ya juste un doigt comme sa coupe et qui
fait ça et c'est horrible bon michael on
t'aime on passe un bon moment tous
ensemble mais maintenant tu prends ce
qu'on appelle un marteau un pied de
biche et tu frappes sur ta mal pour
l'ouvrir s'il te plaît
merci il fallait le faire 24 heures plus
tôt mais ce paraphe c'est bien ouverture
de la malle est ce qu'il ya dedans c'est
des papiers vous êtes déçu moi aussi
quelques heures plus tard michael
revient avec pas mal d'infos c'est les
heures qu'il lui fallait pour
décortiquer tout le contenu de la malle
dans la main il y avait apparemment des
vieux papiers des notes des cartes des
dessins apparemment pas mal effacé à
cause du temps qui est passé est aussi
trois objets michael ouvre le premier
prend des photos et les partager avec
nous et on peut voir que c'est un livre
avec un trou dans la couverture une
vitre et de l'autre côté de la vitre se
trouve une sorte d'objets rougeâtre
qu'on peut vaguement apercevoir mais ce
pas très net dans le deuxième il trouve
une vieille montre et un bol avec une
bougie au milieu et dans le troisième le
truc le plus celle où une boîte
recouverte de plomb alors bien
évidemment tout le monde lui demande
d'ouvrir cette fameuse boîte pour qu'on
voie ce cadre dans et c'est ce que
michael va faire et ce qu'il ya dedans
c'est incompréhensible
il ya un petit flacon poser dans du sel
dans lequel se trouve un petit objet
suspendu à l'aide de ce qui a l'air
d'être un cheveu et le tout est scellée
par une sorte de feuille de métal qui
fait le tour
bref c'est l'objet le plus énigmatique
de tout ce qu'on a pour le moment et
sous le sel qui avait dans la boîte se
trouve une photo de poissons mecs ça
fait combien d'interrogation d'un coup
là 8
elle vient d'où cette malle qui avait
dans ta cave c'est quoi l'histoire de
cette mal qu'est ce qu'elle fout la
demande a capté par an à quelqu'un et
c'est ce qui va faire michael va appeler
son père et ce dernier va lui raconter
que la malle appartenait à son arrière
grand père ce qui est plutôt crédible
puisque c'est vrai que souvent dans les
caves ou dans son grenier on a des
objets qui peuvent dater parfois de une
ou deux générations il ya des trucs
comme ça de famille qui se transmettent
de génération en génération mais moi
y'en a dans la famille sauf que c'est
pas des objets maudit comme celui-là a
l'air de l'être et est apparemment
l'arrière grand père de michael était
dans l'armée il a donc beaucoup voyagé
ce qui selon lui expliquent créé la
présence de cartes de notes de tout un
tas de trucs dans cette malle
on a donc trois éléments et on sait pas
ce que c'est et là du coup les tweets
hausse vont se lancer dans une grosse
recherche vont apporter des infos à
michael pour essayer de comprendre
qu'est ce que c'est que tous ces trucs
tout d'abord il ya quelqu'un qui a
reconnu la page du bouquin qu'on voit et
ce serait celle d'un vieux bouquins de
1886 qui s'appelle le monde avant la
création de l'homme écrit par camille
flammarion et se serait apparemment gros
gros bouquin qui compile 900 gravure
mais à côté de ça plein de gens vont
dire à michael que une boîte de plombs
c'est pas anodin et c'est souvent
utilisé en sorcellerie pour confiner une
entité yes le mec a une relique des
frères warren chez lui et il a ouvert le
conte il explique que lui ça correspond
pas à ses croyances personnelles
il croit pas trop à tout ce délire
d'essence elle rit de tout ça mais il
admet quand même que la présence de sel
le met sur la piste d'une sorte de
sortilèges on n'en sait donc plus sur
deux colis suez dans lequel il y avait
le livre celui dans lequel il y avait la
boîte en plomb mais celui dans lequel il
y avait la montre et le bol avec une
bougie dedans on commet toujours pas à
partir de là on a plus news de michael
jusqu'en début de soirée où il explique
qu'il lui est arrivé un truc très bad
il explique être parti faire ses courses
et que sur le chemin du retour quelqu'un
l'a suivi au qu'est ce que t'es parano
parce que tu as ouvert un truc maudit
peut-être est-ce que c'est l'esprit que
tu viens de libérer en ouvrant cette
[ __ ] de mal tu es en train de te
hanter peut-être je suis heureux de ne
pas avoir de mal dans ma cave l'un qui
ce qu'on est bien arrivé devant son
immeuble mais qu'elle s'est retourné
pour garder le gars qui soupçonne de
l'avoir suivi et le mec a apparemment
immédiatement détourné le regard il a
fait genre d'être sur son téléphone
voilà comme n'importe quel mec qui
panique quand il se fait prendre en flag
du coup notre ami va mettre un petit
warning sur twitter mode bon on a tous
des théories on essaie tous de trouver
des explications rationnelles à ce qui
se passe mais par contre je veux pas que
ça a été ma vie privée donc fait pas des
blagues de genre c'est pas drôle si
quelqu'un a trouvé mon adresse basse
juste pas marrant bref il met un gros
stop au potentiel gens qui seraient
allés trop loin dans le délire mais ça
c'était avant de recevoir un message sur
twitter un peu crépy et oui le lendemain
mais qu'elle reçoit un message privé sur
twitter d'un compte qui s'appelle est et
thiam du père à terre gmes ce qui
ressemble clairement un du lot et le
latin c'est comme c'est comme la bougie
et l'horloge bloqués ça fait partie des
éléments vous c'est non on ne veut pas
ça se compte plus envoyer une vidéo et
le message 3 3 3 à 3h33 dans la nuit
alors la vidéo est dégueulasse mais on
comprend ce qui se passe
quelqu'un a filmé michael à travers sa
fenêtre michael envoie une frontale à ce
mec en lui disant alors je sais pas si
tu m'entends ça le merde mais si tu
recommences j'appelle les flics mais
qu'elle soupçonne l'hypothèse d'un pote
qui lui fait une blague
vu que le thread a pris un peu d'ampleur
et qu'il a fait 1700 retweets est
possible on a tous des potes un peu qui
vont loin dans la blague un des gros
déconneur sauf que il trouve que la
blague est pas drôle et la phrase en
latin veut dire il est trop tard pour
reculer
moi je suis michael je remets tout dans
la malle comme ça je la mets dans du feu
et je change de pays parallèlement
quelqu'un va lui expliquer que 3h33 on
appelle ça leur du prince et ça fait
référence à satan alors cette personne
précise qu'elle n'a aucune idée de 6 et
un rapport si c'est fait exprès ou pas
mais voilà lâche l'info comme ça elle
mais michael en pls et puis elle s'en va
comme ça apparemment à cette heure-là de
la nuit l'écart entre le monde des
vivants et celui des esprits devient
beaucoup plus ténu ce qui peut permettre
d'en trouve rire la porte à certains
malveillants comme les démons les
fantômes c'est l'opposé de trois heures
de l'après-midi lors des miracles qui
est traditionnellement considéré comme
lors de la mort du christ sur sa croix
aucune autre personne qui déclare être
sentaniz va demander à michael si le bol
et la bougie dégage une odeur qui lui
semblerait familiale est effectivement
d'après notre ami le bol dégage une
odeur de soufre
ce qui veut dire selon notre utilisateur
satanistes il ya peut-être une
invocation étant donné que le souffre
est liée dans cette culture là à une
invocation moi je connais rien à tout ce
délire ça me fait bander et je veux pas
connaître je n'ai pas envie de connaître
que ce soit vrai ou faux je n'ai pas
envie de savoir ça ne fait peur dans les
deux cas c'est horrible et il va pas
s'arrêter là le gars et va lui expliquer
que en gros quand un sorcier conclu un
pacte avec le diable il reçoit une
puissance extraordinaire et en échange
de ce pouvoir il doit renier le baptême
est livré son âme aux démons pour
l'éternité savez les fameux pacte avec
le diable qu'il ya eu dans ce jeu sera
du même film et une fois ce marché
conclu satan serait liée à son tour et
serait forcé de billère pour un temps
déterminé et pendant ce temps il se
laisserait par exemple enfermés dans des
objets comme des mâles à huy bref vous
l'avez compris tout le monde parle de
100 céleri à michael il ya tous les
indices d'un délire de sorciers le sel
l'odeur de souffre la bougie la montre
arrêté trou mais malgré tout la nuit
passée elles se passent plutôt bien
puisqu'il ya aucun bruit qui vient de la
mal les choses semblent s'être calmées
jusqu'au lendemain peu après minuit où
michael entend quelqu'un toqués avec
multiples reprises à sa fenêtre il
décide de sortir et de filmer pour avoir
une preuve a montré à la police parce
que souvenez vous il avait dit qu'il
appellerait la police si quelque chose
se repasse dans la vraie vie et c'est le
cas cette fois ci et je vous laisse
regarder cette vidéo
[Musique]
un mec capuche et qui semblait fuir et
qui en voyant michael le poursuivre a
décidé de ne plus fuir de faire l'
inverse 2d fuir et de rochers vers
mickaël rassurez vous il va bien il a
réussi à rentrer chez lui avant de se
faire choper et il a fermé à double tour
sa porte d'entrée et cette fois c'est
bon il décide d'aller voir les flics le
lendemain pourquoi le lendemain parce
qu'il veut pas y aller à des heures où
il ya personne dehors il veut y aller
quand il ya du monde ça le rassure il
est un peu en pls il devait un peu
parano mauvaise nouvelle mais qu'elle
est allée voir les flics et lyon juste
dit ok on peut rien faire pour toi
effectivement avoir une vidéo d'un mec
qui courent vers toi et qui capuche est
bas les flics ils peuvent rien faire ils
vont dire à mr bah ça se reproduit et
cta plus d'infos bien de voir mais là ça
suffit pas et l'après midi ils feront la
meilleure décision il va voir un prêtre
à il était temps sauf qu'une heure plus
tard il aidé eg et traite le prêtre
d'incompétents parce qu'il y aurait
juste dit viens brillé ce soir
dieu te protégera moi je suis agnostique
donc je ne connais rien du tout à la
religion mais en même temps tu voulais
qu'il fasse quoi se prêtent tu veux qui
vient de changer la serrure qui tue et
qui face à part te dire ça en vrai bref
la nuit passe une nouvelle journée
commence
et là c'est un déferlement de mauvaises
nouvelles et on approche en plus la fin
du thread au moment où je fais la vidéo
michael explique qu'il n'arrive plus à
dormir il pense que tout ça a un impact
de ouf sur sa santé mentale
il va même expliqué qui s'est surpris à
se parler tout seul ce qu'il ne fait
apparemment jamais et il aurait cherché
pendant plusieurs heures la provenance
d'une odeur de poisson pourri dans son
appart le latin je suis chiant mais
vraiment le latin la montre la bougie
l'odeur du poisson pourri run away ma
fille prend une décision importante
cette fois il va passer quelques jours
chez une amie à lui et il a une bonne
idée qui est en réalité une très
mauvaise idée c'est d'emmener les colis
ainsi que les cartes qu'il a trouvé dans
la malle tu t'es hanté tout seul et en
plus tu vas entêté amis bien joué il
explique que si ce à quoi il pense est
correct alors il aura besoin des cartes
et du reste mais à quoi ils pensent et
bien écoutez je sais pas et en plus on
va pas avoir de nouvelles pendant 48
heures à partir de là mais il va quand
même finir par nous en donner et nous
expliquer tout d'abord qui va mieux
qu'il a profité de sa quiétude pour se
reposer qu'il a pu faire le point sur la
situation il va aussi en profiter pour
remercier tous les gens qui lui ont
apporté des informations qu'on essayait
de l'aider de le tirer de là et que
toutes les discussions qu'il a pu avoir
avec les gens qui suivait l'histoire
l'ont beaucoup aidé quand il dit tout ça
on sent qu'il a compris le problème qui
sait ce qui se passe mais tu peux pas
trop en dire sous peine de se mettre en
danger il va quand même admettre qu'il a
fait une erreur c'est d'ouvrir cette
[ __ ] de mal et que selon lui
le truc le plus logique à faire ce n'est
pas de refaire mes vêtements la malle et
de la remettre dans la cave
il pense que le vrai problème est
ailleurs c'est quelque chose de beaucoup
plus vieux que c'est quelque chose qui
vient de son arrière grand père que lui
sans temps après il pourra jamais savoir
pourquoi et comment c'est arrivé mais
par contre grâce aux 4 qui l'emmenait
ils pensent savoir où c'est arrivé là on
n'a pas une news depuis six jours romo
jeu mais cette vidéo et les derniers
mois de michael s'était il faut que je
répare les erreurs de mon ancêtre que je
remette les coûts liés à leur place je
peux pas vous en dire plus pour le
moment puisque j'ai peur quand vous
donnant des infos gens donnent aussi à
ceux qui me veulent du mal et je sais
pas qui ils sont mais j'ai pas du tout
envie de tout risquer pour un simple
tweet ne vous inquiétez pas je vous
tiendrai au courant de toute avancée
dans mes recherches
c'était ya six jours mais gaël est ce
que ça va est-ce que c'est toi en amont
qui trouve dans cette manne et qui va
gratter la paroisse de la mal comme ça
pour faire peur à son prochain
propriétaire [ __ ] eh bien écoutez les
amis je crois que nous arrivons à la fin
de ce serait de bons mots je tourne
cette vidéo et je trouve ça très cool
qu'on n'est pas encore la fin ça faisait
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas fait un
thread ou des histoires autour du diable
de la religion des sectes des reliques
de la sorcellerie
j'aimerais le faire ce serait aussi
parce que j'ai reçus après avoir fait
pas mal de vidéos sur les trucs
d'horreur et c'est beaucoup de mails de
gens qui témoignaient des trucs bizarres
et c'était toujours autour de la
religion des trucs qui sont passés dans
leurs enfants genre d crois qu'ils sont
retournés des bref j'ai vu j'ai vu j'ai
reçu plein de trucs de ce genre là et
d'ailleurs les rares films d'horreur
devant lesquelles je suis vraiment mal
c'est ceux qui traitent de ça ça me fait
bad et ça me dépasse ça me met mal je
connais rien de tout ça en plus donc
j'ai pas de 2,2 truc rationnelle pour me
rassurer juge me chie dessus et je fais
j'ai adoré ce thread j'ai hâte de voir
la suite je sais pas quand ce sera mais
il y aura probablement je mettrais bien
du serait du coup dans la description
pour vous puissiez checker la suite en
direct
en tout cas passer une bonne nuit si
vous avez une malle et ben écoute et
mettez la dans la cave et la remontée
jamais un pour cette pluie comme ça vous
dormez bien et aussi à béatrice une
prochaine vidéo au revoir a très vite
[Musique]
vous